let's talk about Alex Jones the Alex
Jones free speech hate speech conspiracy
theorist Fiasco has just exploded
because YouTube has banned Alex Jones
altogether they've ended his channels
existence on YouTube if you go to the
Alex Jones YouTube channel right now you
will merely see a message saying quote
this account has been terminated for
violating YouTube's Community Guidelines
Spotify as I told you had pulled some
podcast episodes Facebook had removed
some video content by Alex Jones I told
you yesterday that iTunes removed the
audio podcasts altogether and now the
big boy
one of the massive moneymakers for Alex
Jones has ended his channel altogether
on YouTube and this story has just grown
and grown
over the last 24 hours and I want to do
the censorship piece justice so I want
to get into more detail about this today
than I did yesterday so first of all so
that we have all the information
why did YouTube ban Alex Jones channel
YouTube's Terms prohibit hate speech and
harassment YouTube says Alex Jones was
publishing both of those things which
clips exactly is not totally clear but
there's plenty of a fodder there right
claiming the parents of Sandy Hook
school shooting victims were crisis
actors promoting Pizza Gate conspiracy
theories which led to the harassment of
the staff and management and ownership
at that comic ping-pong Pizza whatever
it's called blaming the parkland
shooting on the wrong person there's a
very long list here and that is why
YouTube says it has banned the channel
entirely Jones reaction is that he was
the victim of a quote globalist
Deathstar intent on banning
conservatives from platforms like
YouTube and social media he says you can
help him fight that censorship by buying
more of those bogus supplements that he
sells so oh sure never waste a good
opportunity to make some money so now
let's get into the analysis yesterday I
made clear that this isn't a free speech
issue in the legal sense since Spotify
and iTunes and YouTube aren't
government okay I also made clear that
these websites have Community Guidelines
and they determine if you have violated
them so what happened here is totally
legal and in the same way that I've been
demonetised or had videos limited over
time by these platforms so has Alex
Jones the other argument is okay fine
David the companies have Terms of
Service and they can make these
decisions but these companies are so big
and they have so much control over
eyeballs that they're unique in some way
it's not like your local paper saying
they're no longer gonna accept letters
to the editor from Alex Jones the idea
is these companies are so big and
control such market share that they are
tastemakers that's not even the right
word I really need a bigger word and
thus they can't just say we're gonna
block Alex Jones if your argument is
that they're too big to be bound by the
or to be have the same freedoms that
normal smaller businesses should you
have maybe the problem is that they got
so big in the first place except I don't
hear conservatives trying to prevent
companies like YouTube from getting as
big as they have gotten I mean it's a
fair argument to make right because
YouTube does seem like it's becoming a
monopoly there isn't a clear competitor
to it Facebook you can say the same
thing maybe to a lesser degree but if
you want to make those a public
commodity you have to do that because
you believe in the principle not just
because you're against Alex Jones being
banned from those platforms and not
starting to talk about it
only when Alex Jones has been banned
from those platforms so that's the legal
situation now that being said I don't
like this I don't like this and I want
to explain to you why I do like the fact
that Alex Jones is disgusting vile
dangerous material is going to be less
accessible so if that's what YouTube
wants to do legally I don't have a
problem with it but I believe that the
spirit of platforms like YouTube should
be if it's not illegal then allow it
advertisers have to have the right to
say we don't want our ads showing up on
the Alex Jones channel if that's their
prerogative if that's what they want
there shouldn't be child porn allowed
there shouldn't be direct threats
against specific people that ones
actually kind of bored
because the pizza gate stuff from Alex
Jones arguably did lead to threats
against specific people but the theme is
even if this is okay to do by YouTube I
don't think it's a good direction the
views of people like Alex Jones should
be ostracized and discredited ideally
ignored they should be so obviously
ridiculous that they have no impact as a
policy I opted on the side of allow it
if it's legal because once you start
picking and choosing it's about whether
you like the choices YouTube or Facebook
or whoever makes now this is blurry and
complex because I do think that these
platforms have a responsibility to
police content responsibly if
individuals are being targeted or
harassed if the content is criminal then
they do have a responsibility to deal
with that and they can make these
decisions but I would prefer in the
absence of illegal content for
individual pieces of content that are
offending the policy the kite guidelines
Terms of Service to be removed rather
than entire channels in addition once
you start doing this people are going to
point out and rightly so
YouTube is filled with horrible channels
channels that have been pointed out
lately which have not been blocked or
banned including channels where parents
do horrible things to their kids a
borderline and including child abuse and
all sorts of other stuff so part of this
isn't just the content of the videos but
it's the relative impact and the PR
around them and that's where it starts
to get dicey because it became
groupthink among these different
platforms - all at the same time say
that's gonna do it for Alex Jones so
legally I don't see a problem but I
don't like this and I recognize that
just because it's happening to Alex
Jones now and not me
it could happen to me even if I've not
put up a legal content merely because of
the sort of shifting interpretation of
what the community guidelines are yeah I
really hate that pile on effects that we
see from some of these platforms like
because Spotify takes down some of his
episodes that means that Facebook and
YouTube have to ban them even though
those platforms for the longest time
expressed that they want to keep Alex
Jones's channel up out of the principle
of free
so that's a little bit disconcerting and
I know people are gonna write in to me
pat and say David are you defending Alex
Jones or are you defending his content
no I'm not doing either I think that the
content as I said is vile depraved and
disgusting and it's anything that leads
to fewer people seeing it is a good
thing in terms of the ends the means are
something I worry about because it is
open to significant subjectivity once
you say it's not illegal content and I
do understand why YouTube did it I get
why iTunes did it this is not only a PR
liability but if Alex Jones loses a
lawsuit against the Sandy Hook families
soon which might these platforms could
be worried about legal liability for
having allowed the offending content but
once again what I want to circle back to
is the analysis from yesterday stands
which is this is what it looks like when
businesses make decisions that are best
for them just because YouTube is huge
doesn't mean they have to carry it
unless of course it's determined that in
on the basis of the 1966 Supreme Court
case Evans V Newton it's a private
company that is endowed with sort of
pseudo governmental powers or as an
agency of the state because they are so
big that's not been determined here
legally speaking but in the meantime the
problem is people will start to say if
this one why not that one people have
been emailing me about steven crowder
saying David in a lot of his videos he's
sort of bullying people and harassing
people it isn't this over the line isn't
it hate and that's why it gets very
complex yeah it's the classic slippery
slope argument and maybe you could say
the same thing about us that maybe we're
next and you know we don't defame people
here in the David Pakman show and we
don't issue any threats of violence we
tend to save that for the bonus show or
of course you know it could raise some
red flags oftentimes slippery slopes
should be resisted when they don't make
sense other times you have to consider
is there actually any protection against
a slippery slope and I think that this
is a borderline case for sure